[Music]
on a chilly Thursday morning in Calgary
police Gather in an empty parking lot
they have come to this quiet suburb to
go over the plan to search a nearby home
so we'll just approach to the front door
uh we'll just do kind of soft knocks and
enter
it's not just the suspect thereafter
it's the evidence computers phones any
electronic devices that could contain
child sexual abuse material more
commonly known as child pornography
record no History of Violence Detective
Lee Hafner is the lead on this case and
her backup is detective Dean Jacobs
there are dedicated police units to
fight these types of crimes this one is
the Southern Alberta internet child
exploitation unit ice when I started in
2013 I don't even think we'd hit 400
cases for the whole year there's been a
steady increase probably 20 30 percent
each year and this year we will probably
hit close to 1500 cases
and that number only accounts for half
of Alberta nationally data collected
from statistics Canada paints a
disturbing picture between 2017 and 2021
there were about 30 000 online child
luring and making and distributing child
porn reports to police this in itself is
an epidemic we investigate the clear net
we rarely even dive down into the dark
net which is truly where those really
really bad people are functioning and
there's another threat sexual
exploitation or sextortion of minors has
been growing at an alarming rate
especially in 2022 we were noting in the
first six months that we had had 150
percent increase in the number of
reports related to sex extortion
extortion is a form of online blackmail
where criminals deceive children through
various digital platforms to obtain
explicit images victims are then
extorted for money or more material
Steven Sauer oversees Canada's youth tip
line for online sex crimes in July alone
they had more than 300 reports up from
40 just two years ago about 90 percent
of the extortion victims that are
reporting to us are young males but
those unsettling figures don't even come
close to the real numbers of kids being
victimized many feel ashamed and too
embarrassed to come forward sextortion
is one of those things where there's a
lot of victim blaming that you complied
with that request to send the picture
you shouldn't have done that and I think
that is that is the silencing Factor
that's why this mother who we are
calling Sarah has asked not to be
identified her teenage son was a victim
of sex extortion and she fears he will
be stigmatized she's speaking out to
warn other parents
can you take me back to January of this
year and tell me what happened I was
just about asleep when my son came
running into my room very distraught
very upset he literally came in the room
hyperventilating had to get a bag and
get him to put his head between his legs
and breathe while I figured out what was
going on and I figured it out pretty
darn fast looking at the phone
the perpetrator convinced her son who
was 15 years old at the time to send a
sexually explicit video he believed he
was flirting with a young woman this
person led him to believe they were
sexting let's do it on video while the
video was recorded and then used it as
blackmail for the money instantly
instantly
boys are getting extorted for money the
extorter is looking for a financial
gains from our targets and the boys will
send a picture or a video they would
then get a message immediately back
saying well thanks for the picture but I
want money now from you
out of fear some of them pay others
don't girls are being targeted too
experts say but the offenders tend to be
interested in them sexually so girls are
being blackmailed for more content the
perpetrators extorting boys are often
tied to organized crime yeah
and engage in Sharing sexual images
authorities say some organized groups
are based out of Nigeria Ivory Coast and
Southeast Asia but Predators could be
anywhere in the world there's no borders
with the internet so these guys can go
and work anywhere and so can we
so police have to reach out to other law
enforcement agencies for help with this
particular crime we are reaching out to
the Ivory Coast and reaching out to
Nigeria through Department of Homeland
Security and the FBI and then they're
reaching out to their Partners there to
try to locate and arrest these targets
how much money did they ask for I think
it was 500 immediately or the video
would be shared with all of his friends
and family and very persistently text
bubble after tax bubble after text
bubble that this person is going to ruin
his life by Distributing content
Sarah told her son to block the person
immediately but it didn't help the
offender sent the video to her son's
friends and family on Facebook he lost
his girlfriend he also lost a lot of his
friends it's heartbreaking to watch
their life crumble and there's nothing
you can do about it
you seem like you have a pretty close
relationship with your son what do you
think would have happened if he didn't
come to you
oh my goodness he would not have been
emotionally able to handle anything
in recent years a terrifying pattern has
emerged some sextortion victims fearing
No Way Out have taken their own lives
sometimes within hours of being targeted
it is truly terrifying to have this
happen to you
in Miami social psychologist Asia Eaton
turned her attention towards studying
cyber sexual abuse to help lawmakers
understand its impact on survivors what
she found was a portrait of overwhelming
emotional distress from being victimized
I was an expert witness just recently
for a victim Survivor Coupe called a
suicide hotline very shortly after she
began to be sex daughter because she
felt that there was no other Escape
Eaton points to the fact that kids
Social Circles are much smaller than
adults so they feel there's nowhere to
hide
there's no safe place there's nowhere to
retreat from these images and the
harassment that follows them I found
that individuals suffer from physical
strain as well as emotional strain
stomach aches headaches sleeplessness
waking up in the middle of the night
panicked
looking online to see if one's images
have spread further so the consequences
are tremendous
there have been cases where victims have
ended up taking their own lives did you
ever have that fear absolutely and
that's why as soon as the next morning I
got him into counseling had we not done
that immediately and taken such fast
action I don't think we'd have our son
today
just killing the numbers
back with ice detectives Hafner and
Jacobs are driving to the suspect's
house
so we just had the briefing with our ice
units what the plan is when we
approached the house and how we're going
to enter so that everybody is on the
same page
in a matter of minutes the team rolls up
on the scene with them our Patrol
officers and the Tactical Unit just in
case they need to force open the door
speed is critical there's always a risk
that the suspect inside will be tipped
off and Destroy any potential evidence
foreign
it's 7 A.M and the ice team is moving in
on a suspect's home City police open the
door
hi good morning please please
today's search is part of an
investigation involving child sexual
abuse material or csam for short the
unit has been working on this file for
over a year
you can manually Do It Yourself by lead
forensic examiner Alan LaFontaine and
detective Justin Brooks are setting up
Myrtle a mobile evidence recovery
technology lab that's vital to catching
criminals not all ice units can afford
to have a mobile forensic unit so we're
Super Lucky it is life-altering for how
we do business
that's because officers can search and
seize items and bring them here for the
text to review
traditionally before exhibits have to
come back to the office and get
subjected to a full forensic analysis
which is time huge amount of time so
with Myrtle we can typically drill them
down to okay we only need three of those
items because the rest have no
evidentiary value
this is his current cell phone okay uh
that was on his chair
since the examiners are able to crack
open most of the devices on site they're
able to put the pieces of the puzzle
together fast
Detective Lee Hafner is in charge of the
case it's invaluable because they're
able to find the evidence very quickly
and so that helps direct the next steps
of the investigation over the course of
the next hour exhibits roll in a
computer tower laptop flash drive and
broken phones there's a USB drive if you
want to look at that USB drive yeah the
tech team is meticulously checking it
all it's like a trail of breadcrumbs and
you solve each one in order like can we
find a device that is being used for
these offenses and then if you can find
that device is the data still there that
we're looking for
officers arrest the suspect and take him
in for questioning detectives Hafner and
Dean Jacobs head to the station to
interview him
back in Myrtle examiners are running
into hurdles so far they haven't found
any illegal material they think it's on
this cell phone but the team doesn't
have the code
and trying to decrypt it has been
challenging
they don't have to give us their
password
other jurisdictions in the UK If you
don't give your password it can be used
against you
that's no go on this phone
they need to take the device back to
headquarters to use another machine to
get it open
we are done with searching uh we are
just we have a few more phones just to
eliminate
the team was alerted to this alleged
perpetrator through a series of tips we
would see 12 different reports from two
different social networking sites
American Service Providers must report
see Sam to the National Center for
missing and exploited children or face
fines up to three hundred thousand
dollars U.S if it's discovered they
didn't and then based on where the IP is
the report gets disseminated to the
respective law enforcement agency in
that jurisdiction
for police getting warnings from social
media firms is key youth are frequently
being targeted by Predators on these
platforms and are either being asked for
videos pictures or money I don't think
people truly understand the scope of the
problem and the amount of material that
is on the internet we're inundated it's
like shoveling water it's never ending
Jacobs has been a detective with ice for
almost 15 years it's a tough job you see
a lot of bad things but to be able to
tell a parent that the arrested the bad
guy it makes me feel good and I know it
makes the rest of my team feel good too
and he's working on getting Justice for
this mother Jane whose identity we are
protecting says her daughter was
extorted by a U.S registered sex
offender more than two years ago
she was on her iPad playing a game
called adopt me through Roblox and I
just thought she was playing this game
that all her friends play
I had no clue other than my parents
saying there's something not right with
her she's not herself
I would have never guessed it was
something online
that she was being harassed by a
predator her daughter was only nine
years old then the alleged offender in
his 40s he made it real simple and I'll
give you these special characters and
made her feel comfortable with him
and then as things went along he asked
for the naked pictures and naked video
and then he was starting to threaten to
send the pictures to family and friends
and she got really worried she said she
cried herself to sleep every night
because she was so so scared
the perpetrators are not
looking for children randomly they're
intentionally seeking out children who
might be more vulnerable either more
vulnerable to their approach or or more
likely to succumb to pressure
in eastern Ontario Michael cedo is the
forensic research director at the Royal
Ottawa Healthcare Group he has spent
more than two decades trying to
understand what drives online child
sexual predators
in the 80s and 90s for child sexual
abuse we really focused on stranger
danger and more recently we're really
seeing a lot of the same kind of message
about what you reveal online
offenders are often Master manipulators
ceto says they're very skilled at
creating opportunities to exploit
children it's not necessarily upfront
like just asking somebody for for nudes
or something like that although that
does happen as well there is this period
of grooming where it's getting the young
person to feel like you're somebody that
they like and somebody that they can
trust and so then maybe it's not as
shocking or disturbing when you know sex
is introduced
for officers fighting these crimes at
the street level it could be almost
anyone thereafter every age group
demographic ethnicity profession there
is no typical offender
and many of them don't have a criminal
record majority of our offenders are
first time I think a lot of people would
be surprised to hear that yeah and I
think that's one of the interesting
parts of our job is when we get to talk
to people about these types of offenses
and why they've committed them so
whether it's they got addicted to
pornography and it wasn't doing it for
them anymore and they kind of went down
the rabbit hole of child sexual abuse
material it could be somebody who truly
is a pedophile and has a sexual
attraction to children and then there's
a variety of reasons in between those
how did you find out your daughter was
being exploited I found out through text
and she said Mommy I've done something
seriously really really wrong and I'm so
so so so so sorry and she went on to
explain there was a man that had asked
her to send some naked pictures and
videos and she would get some characters
and she said I did it Mom
I called the Calgary police right away
the case was then handed over to ice
that case is still a work in progress
but working with the FBI we were able to
arrest the individual
so this is not over for you no not until
there's a final verdict
laws around online sexual exploitation
vary depending on where you live the
Canadian government has been considering
legislation to tackle the problem but
the proposed bill has been widely
criticized there's much more that we
need to be doing as a country Canada is
only starting down the road now of
looking at an online safety Bill and
really nothing has come into place
Steven Sauer of cybertip.ca says Canada
should adopt similar laws as Australia
recently the Australian government
enacted legislation to compel companies
to provide information on the steps that
they are taking to combat sexual
exploitation in their platforms it also
created an agency with the power to
pressure companies to remove content and
if they don't comply the Australian
government can find them quite heavily
at the scene after hours of searching
and coming up empty examiners say they
found disturbing videos
Maybe
that's enough for me right now I'm
struggling
she's showing her press yeah and she's
eight yeah
this discovery could be key to laying
charges LaFontaine talks to the
detectives about what they've uncovered
throughout the morning they have been in
constant contact
I think the laptop yields three offenses
The Examiner send a screen grab of what
they found to detectives so that they
could use it during their interview with
the suspect this ultimately led to okay
you got me here's my password so yeah
crucial crucial
the suspect is now facing five charges
it's too soon to tell what the outcome
will be the allegations will need to be
tested in court
directions done in the house
we're about to release
one thing is clear in an increasingly
Digital World online sexual exploitation
of children is virtually impossible to
stop
it's prolific and it's a problem that
police can't solve alone
many given day there's probably hundreds
thousands of of targets within our
jurisdiction knowing that you can only
just scratch the surface of what's going
on that to me is the toughest part of of
my job I think that's the fear of
everybody in this unit is missing a
child that's being abused at the end of
the day the victims of the crime are the
most vulnerable in our society we all
need to work together it's not just the
police problem we're not going to arrest
our way out of this we need help from
everybody